[Music]
what happens at elton john's oscar park
it's a celeb
city it's so
so awesome you know uh stephen tyler
over here nicki minaj
was at the table um next to us and i did
a nicki minaj song on glee what nicki
minaj a super bass
it's not a it's a wrap dude it's a rock
yeah it's a wrap
do you know it you know i do let me see
uh this one is for the boys with the
boom and system top down ac with the
coolant system when he come up on the
club people blazing up he got stacks on
deck like saving up and he ill he real
he might got a deal he popped bottles
and he got the right kind of [ __ ]
fantastic it took me
so hard that is fantastic thank you and
you know what you can use that so many
times in your life absolutely i have all
of these skills now that are just going
to get me so far but you know it is true
like you're going to find another time
in your life when you can just jump into
that exactly if someone's giving you
attitude at a car rental counter and
just go into that
exactly and they don't expect it from a
six foot you know white lady